I'm always recommend I recommend our
crab and artichoke dip okay let's get
one of those all right
Philips triple tower yes what's that
it's a three tiered tower of three
different appetizers and he's nine big
enough on the menu they're also
suffering from small man syndrome it's
good for that and then the butternut
ravioli let's try that all right thanks
- nice to see so the appetizers first
please okay well I'm feeling really
nervous about cooking for Gordon
they're all [ __ ] throws together most
of the food is prepackaged or canned or
frozen because ginger and Phillip were
running this place like real misers they
pinch a penny on every corner this is
our crab and artichoke dip it's served
with deep fried pita bread and there's a
fresh crab all canned frozen Chilean
crab frozen Chilean crab correct
[ __ ] snob dip
I mean it's like a dish ready for wanna
Philips girlfriends no teeth oh god it's
got a sour taste to know what it is
Jesus he felt it tasted sour it always
got that taste to me I don't like it you
are kidding me this is the towel the
towel my gosh
holy mackerel so it's like something
should have in your [ __ ] garden
what was the restaurant all those shrimp
are they fresh are they frozen they're
frozen they're frozen too damn discuss
them and what's him here their teriyaki
beef tips Jesus a sauce is hideous but
that's just tough beef tips is like beef
chew and that middle ones another
portion of snot dip I'll skip that well
unfortunately for the chef he doesn't
get to dictate his own menu but the chef
doesn't know his own menu he does not
let's move on shall we oh my god careful
so Phillips dictating the menu I suppose
if the staff can't be trusted to talk in
and out they can't be trusted to choose
the food
feedback on that the meat is too tough
the sauce tastes weird he can tell it's
not homemade you're just Ramsay's and it
is the meat is too tough getting the
full picture and that's just what I
wanted right feel very good about it I
am very disappointed with Sam food is
horrible I just hope that Gordon sees
the problems with the staff ravioli I'm
you're heading bringing this dish out to
him right now the better not rapidly
thank you
who made these rarities I don't know the
name of the manufacturer manufacture
correct
so the robberies on ebay diva they are
not made here Jesus they're packaged
[Music]
dreadfully like a mouthful of sugar
every time oh dear take it oh wow frozen
crap frozen shrimp prepackaged ravioli
it's more like eating the bad leave an
old folks home than a decent restaurant
a better way to the art kitchen
commotion and it's functioning right now
I see this blatant leg laughs tell me
about Philips mother's Mustafa well when
he's sober I get along with him just
fine when he's drinking I avoid him at
all costs
does he drink a lot I'm sorry
boss kinda wants to satin how about is
he drinking now again this week he was
arrested for what DUI you are [ __ ]
kidding me I'm not kidding
oh my god I want to see the hotel owner
jailed jailed it was kept overnight in
jail bloody hell why would you not tell
me that when it just happened hours ago
Philips in denial he doesn't take
responsibility for his drinking problems
and I felt Gordon needed to know to come
out why don't you ask the chef to come
out of the diner I'd like to meet him
I'm bringing it Philip and ginger as
well thank you yeah we like to see you
all in the dining room
[Music]
I'm not so where's chef that was
dreadful
I don't think anything was fresh it
takes extra time to do things
homemade yeah that's right we're on a
time restraint what ask how many hours
they get in a week or whatever and they
got a scrape for my prep cook gets 20
hours a week that's not enough time to
make fresh food is that why all the
food's frozen I mean I get cut carrots
or cut celery in the bag
I get the boiled eggs in a bag done
peeled you volume boiled eggs yes I
played the save card and purchase
suppose were prepared
you played the safe card recording boil
a [ __ ] egg in here Philip if you care
about quality you need to pay people to
prep fresh food not buy it in there are
times a your january/february I'd have
12 16 hours a week a week yeah how did
you survive three hours a day not very
well but you're family yet a different
Dan seven kids this is insane you can't
run this hotel like a miser if I sold
[ __ ] three of those cars and put it
into the kitchen budget to function for
the next 12 months the chefs can do
their job and speaking of cars wait tell
me about this